moi je viens parce que j'étais son agent
artistique avant d'être son agent
artistique j'avais créé des liens
d'amitié or je vous dis honnêtement je
faisais 40 kilos de moins donc j'étais
quand même pas trop moche on n'a jamais
dragué
moi je viens
certes je n'étais pas sur les moments en
présence des faits
tout ça ce que vous disiez non alors si
on va dire combien de fois il m'a dit
qu'on allait en soirée ce soir tu fais
ta bimbo parce que je m'habiller plus
serré j'ai une grosse poitrine mais si
on peut plus rire on est dans le showbiz
il va falloir arrêter un petit peu le
délire alors je sais qu'il y a des faits
qui sont vraies mais je ne citerai pas
de nom mais mon grand-père qui est
décédé qui était un grand producteur
il avait 85 ans mais les actrices de 25
ans et 21 ans qui habitaient chez lui ou
qui couchait avec lui elle savait pas
honte de coucher avec lui pour avoir
85 ans et coucher avec des filles mais
bien sûr
mais bien sûr et je peux vous le dire
qu'il avait des Supers Nanas pour
devenir
ça donne de l'espoir mais Cyril c'est
pas mais on va être honnête vous qui a
que des doigts vous avez plein de femmes
derrière juste vous avez un métier
l'amitié on oublie qui sont les
personnes réellement moi je viens pour
dire je ne dis pas que les actrices sont
des menteuses on est d'accord je pense
que la justice elle est là pour faire
son métier mais j'aimerais que ça
s'arrête même moi aujourd'hui
j'ai des gens parce que on me dit aussi
et on m'accuse en me disant mais vous
avez pas honte vous avez été agent
artistique de tirer s'amitier je suis
son agent enfin j'ai été son agent parce
que il a des qualités professionnelles
et des qualités humaines et je suis pas
responsable moi mon métier c'est de
connaître de mettre des artistes de
l'ombre à la lumière et puis de les
garder à la lumière mais aussi mais mon
rôle d'agent artistique c'est être la
maman la seconde maman c'est ça mon
métier être la psychologue la confidente
et je viens je suis plus sous contrat
avec Thierry donc j'étais pas obligé de
venir et mon métier normalement c'est
être une femme de l'ombre pas de
m'exposer c'est pas mon métier de
m'exposer dire à tout le monde
vous est-ce que vous l'avez trouvé
est-ce que parfois c'est quoi vous dites
il est un peu lourd mais Thierry il est
joueur il est draguer j'en connais plein
je citerai pas mais il y en a plein
comme ça aussi je non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que maintenant on est
dans une époque où les femmes à force
excusez-moi du terme on vous donnera un
jour porter la burqa parce que même si
on est en mini-jupe ça va pas si on met
on met en à l'aise notre poitrine ça va
pas et si un homme va nous faire des
compliments sur notre poitrine
excusez-moi je parle de ma personne par
exemple ça y est les femmes vont sentir
agressées et du coup on fait plus de
compliments enfin parce qu'on est dans
un monde où tout est renfermé ou c'est
on a plus rien de grandir on a plus rien
droit de faire les hommes ils ont plus
loin
mais c'est pas la même chose
je suis entièrement d'accord mais
j'essaye de rentabiliser je ne s'il y a
eu agression je n'étais pas là sur les
il faut qu'il mérite ça vous a étonné
vous êtes tombé des nues alors quand moi
je vous explique honnêtement j'étais
déjà sous contrat avec Thierry quand moi
on m'a contacté et qu'on m'a tenu
j'étais voir Thierry j'étais lui
demander qu'est-ce qui se passe on a été
boire un café voilà et là il ne m'a pas
menti la déballer il a pas essayé de me
chercher voilà je sais qu'il aime bien
draguer les femmes voilà qu'il est lourd
parce que c'est un homme qui est un peu
farfelu qui très intelligent et puis
dans sa tête il est un peu dans sa bulle
un peu mais comprenez la même chose de
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor qu'il aimait les
femmes c'est un séducteur voyez donc en
fait après il y a une frontière
si vous voulez moi je viens parler de ma
place d'agent d'accord
donc je lui ai parlé le but c'est de se
dire qu'est-ce qui se passe de laisser
faire aussi la justice
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit dans mes
interviews si vous voulez relisez 2019
et vous a dit quoi alors comme vous
l'avez vu vous l'avez dit c'est
Christophe
alors moi ce que je dirais aussi
au niveau des rapports du problème de la
production moi ce qu'il m'a dit
honnêtement c'est qu'il y avait un
problème c'est que la pièce ne
fonctionnait pas et qui avait déjà un
problème de mauvaise entente entre tous
acteurs dedans je dis bien je n'étais
pas là d'accord je dis juste les propos
parce que attention il faut toujours
faire très attention à ce qu'on dit on
est d'accord mais quand vous l'avez dit
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous a
dit oui j'étais au loin avec elle ou pas
du tout
elle m'a dit que c'était toujours sa
façon de faire de draguer de sa façon il
me dit voilà tu sais vaina je suis il a
jamais nié qu'il était lourd d'accord
parce que c'est son tempérament d'être
lourd d'être mais moi bon le coup du
sexe pour les réaction
il m'a pas dit qu'il l'avait niait parce
que c'est un sujet qu'on a pas parlé ou
une fois il m'avait dit mais non c'est
pas vrai
les bisous pendant les représentations
il met la langue il m'en a pas parlé
voilà
que il soit lourd à faire des paroles de
drague très lourdes pas voilà c'est dans
son tempérament
donc ça a toujours été ce qui s'est
passé quand en 2019 parce que j'étais
son agent à cette période là
moi j'ai essayé de prendre contact avec
Monsieur Franck Leboeuf c'est pas parce
que je suis son agent alors en privé
pour lui demander qu'est-ce qui se passe
qui normalement il défend les femmes
Monsieur Franck Leboeuf champion du
monde de foot c'est très bien soulager
une femme qui lui dit voilà je me
présente je suis l'agent artistique de
Thierry Samitier donnez moi votre
version je voudrais discuter avec vous
et qu'on m'envoie des messages que j'ai
toujours
ou c'est pas du tout un tempérament je
pense que voilà je pense que là il y a
aussi une guéguerre de
AMP c'est-à-dire que en MP en message
privé lui d'avoir de la communication
avec moi gentiment parce que je n'ai je
lui expliquais j'étais justement son
nouveau agent je voudrais savoir ce qui
se passe quand m'éclaircisse je pense
que dans ce métier là un peu comme qui
joue avec lui
la seule chose c'est pas bien
d'espionner les contes des autres alors
je dis fortement Monsieur Franck Leboeuf
j'attends toujours qu'on se parle en
tant qu'adulte
dans cette sauce hein
moi que ça soit productions moi ce que
je voudrais juste éclaircir moi je le
comprends aussi
il faut qu'on parle de l'affaire Thierry
Messenger
cette culture et un peu d'intelligence
je sais tourner mes phrases d'accord je
sais donner aussi mon numéro de
téléphone en donnant mon identité en
disant voilà
avant que ça soit étalé au niveau voilà
avant qu'il passe venir tirer s'amitier
ici d'accord donc tout simplement
c'était pour savoir qu'est-ce qui se
passe
Monsieur Franck Leboeuf et je n'ai rien
contre lui mais je pense aussi que il
faut savoir rester neutre et se
positionner sur l'emplacement de tout le
monde et peut-être qu'il voulait
réserver sa parole auprès de la police
il a du succès avec les femmes Thierry
bah honnêtement
comment vous dire
cette question qui se pose aussi en vrai
les mecs c'est vrai on se pose la
question
je connaissais et je connaissais ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est accompagné d'une très belle femme
dans sa vie
après moi mon métier c'est agent
artistique c'est de connaître mes
artistes d'accord professionnel je
connais aussi personnellement
après ils font ce qu'ils veulent de leur
vie à côté bon bien sûr quand ça dépasse
les limites non c'est pas bien là
aussi dire c'est je fais mon métier
d'agent artistique et quand après parce
que j'étais son agent on me détruit pour
dire parce que je suis son agent
tu as pris le contrat depuis cette
histoire des contrats tu as des contrats
de plus cette histoire ou ça c'est alors
avec Thierry on avait plus du tout de
contrat même un producteur est-ce que
les autres ça a été très difficile alors
par exemple on va en parler vous avez un
chroniqueur Jean-Marie Bigard qui ne
connaît très bien une fois on a fait un
vidéo on mangeait ensemble excusez-moi
je connais j'étais à son restaurant
manger ensemble on a fait une vidéo il a
appelé ma fille ce qu'on avait des
projets avec Jean-Marie on rigole bien
vous connaissez ça je passe des moments
tout de suite les gens paf c'est on n'a
pas le droit parce qu'on est dans dans
le showbiz ou dans une personnalité
publique on n'a pas le droit de rigoler
de discuter parce que bah tout de suite
par exemple Jean-Marie fait à traiter de
d'alcoolique ou des choses comme ça moi
aussi j'aime bien boire j'aime bien
manger hein ça se voit non ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas parce
qu'on est des personnalités publiques on
n'a pas le droit à vivre après les
erreurs même personnalité publique on
doit faire face à la justice voilà et
que
la vie des gens à côté c'est qu'il y a y
a eu des faits répétés que des metteur
en scène l'ont prévenu que même sur les
chers voisins étaient il a été recadré
et que malgré tout malgré tout le récit
dit vrai c'est différent
mais on le sait tous qu'il est Lourdin
non mais c'est dans son attitude je vais
pas vous mentir vu que pour certains
vous le connaissez aussi mais c'est le
bon gars c'est pas quelqu'un de méchant
la jeune fille la jeune fille elle a
vécu un enfer apparemment
je dis bien que pour moi attention ne
faites pas dire si c'est passé vraiment
quelque chose il faut laisser faire
l'enquête et puis il faut laisser faire
la justice et puis Laura ce qui mérite
tout simplement enquêter depuis le dépôt
de plainte depuis un an et là ils
estiment avoir assez d'éléments pour
confronter monsieur Samitier donc on
rappelle la présomption d'innocence il y
a un grand écart entre le contenu de la
plainte et ses déclarations à lui et
celle de son avocat puisque son avocat a
toujours nié et contesté les gestes
inappropriés que lui annie est
totalement donc l'écart est-elle qui a
besoin d'une garde à vue aux yeux des
enquêteurs pour faire la lumière sur la
ferme voilà donc présomption d'innocence
mais un témoignage circonstancié une
plainte sérieuse et c'est pour ça que
les enquêteurs vont faire toute la
lumière au fil de la garde à vue sur ce
qui s'est réellement passé et sur les
suites à donner ou pas à cette affaire
voilà d'accord
je n'ai jamais dit que les plaintes
n'étaient pas assez d'argent
je ne suis pas contre non plus les
actrices parce que si c'est des faits
réels ça le mérite pas mais je pense que
moi ce que je viens c'est dire que dans
le domaine du showbiz comme du même du
public de faire la part des choses voilà
chacun fait son métier moi j'ai fait mon
métier de défendre Thierry s'amitier ça
c'est toujours bien passé voilà il y a
eu des hauts et des bas comme tout les
artistes les agents parfois on se prend
la tête voilà c'est tout à fait normal
c'est notre métier mais faire la part
des choses voilà Thierry il a aussi une
maman il a une sœur
que vous avez raison de bien le préciser
on le précise encore voilà il est
présumé nos 100 il faut attendre voilà
parce que il faut pas non plus parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle le jugement
médiatique comme on dit un pro cès
médiatique et c'est vrai que derrière
c'est très compliqué de se remettre
aussi donc voilà